Knowledge based is a dominate field with a very active research program. There
are number of exiting projects going on right now. Here is a small list of them.
CALO is a project, in which cognitive assistant learns and organizes knowledge.
CALO, in fact was a pick cursor for the CD program of Apple. Cyc and OMCS.
OMCS stands for Open Mind Common Sense. Cyc and OMCS are two large knowledge
bases to support everyday common sense of reasoning. Wolfram Alpha is a new kind
of search engine that uses some of the same kind of pilot structures we have
considered in this particular class, different from many of the search engines.
The three projects in the right column are projects here at Georgia Tech. VITA
is a computational model of visual thinking in autism. And particular it solves
problems in the real world raven's progressive matrices test using only visual
spacial representations. Dramatis is a computational model suspense in drama and
stories. Recall that in this class we talked about the theory of humor and
surprise. Dramatis tries to do the same thing for suspense. DANE is a system for
supporting design based on analogies to natural systems. We've come across this
idea of biologically inspired design earlier in the class and DANE supports that
kind of biologically inspired design. We have provided references for
these and many other knowledge based AI projects in the class notes.
Your welcome to explore depending on your inquests.